[inaudible].
It is the fifth most valuable company in
the wells.
Each minutes of the company brings in
more than $250,000
it's income in 2016 was more than $136
billion and you know what's the best
part is the company is only 23 years
old.
[inaudible]
this is to say according to our
demographics there at visual politic,
Amazon is probably younger than you.
That was a time in history when the most
powerful nations look to build huge
empires.
The British,
the Spanish,
the Romans,
the Mongols.
Today things are rather different though
it seems that the great nations of years
past to being substituted by new massive
technology corporations.
As an example of this,
we have the Amazon App.
When this it is not just a figure of
speech.
Let's imagine that you wanted to buy
Amazon,
which is now the unquestionable leader
of the commerce.
Have you got any idea how much you would
have to pay for this company?
Come on,
just try and guess at it.
Well,
the actual figure is $420 billion as of
the recording of this video,
that's nearly half a trillion dollars,
which is a truly incredible figure.
This is because Amazon stock has tripled
since 2015 which has made Amazon the
unquestionable star of the market as
this is not just a matter of numbers.
It's also a matter of reality.
I mean,
who hasn't heard of Amazon?
I'm as an is Dhea view the biggest
ecommerce company in the wells,
but oh,
that is so much more.
Did you know that it's also the world's
leader in Web services?
I'm the still more than that.
24 hour delivery,
ebooks,
tablets,
cloud services,
and even trucks,
planes and ships.
Right now,
while you're watching this video,
Amazon is working out how to reduce
their dependence on big logistics
companies,
notably with the company deciding to
move into the shipping industry and a
great deal of the company's success can
be put down to its delivery time with
some deliveries today,
even happening on the same day as the
order.
Why don't we set everything as it does
is in the online world,
this is starting to
change the leaders of the company,
especially the president and main
shareholder.
Jeff Bezos want to occupy the entire
market and they've realized that sill
more than 90% of all purchases are made
in traditional brick and mortar shops.
What does it happen to?
This potential of the company leaders
have set the goal of revolutionizing
commerce,
not just ecommerce,
but physical commerce.
Well,
this has already started.
Amazon already has several bookstores
available in the United States and even
about to open Amazon,
go to the public,
the first supermarket without cashiers
prized whether you should be.
Because what Amazon is looking to do is
dominate this market as well.
And as well as Amazon is apt to do,
they will keep on trying until they
succeed.
Up until now,
most offline companies,
both big,
medium,
and small have suffered because of
online competition.
So imagine what could happen if Amazon
brings its competition to the physical.
Yes.
Marquez
not at all.
Think of the consequences that can arise
from the automation of jobs in this
area,
which is Bali.
The way,
one of the areas which employs the most
people.
All right,
so it's still too soon to have the media
concerns,
but if you own a store or your work in
one,
maybe it's time to consider what's going
to happen over the coming years.
Yes,
Amazon effect
recurring messages during Donald Trump's
presidential campaign was the
competition with countries like China or
Mexico was making American industry
disappear.
That is why in order to protect and
recover all of those jobs from seeks to
put barriers against foreign trade,
specifically targeting imports.
The problem in here,
folks,
as we have already seen in previous
visual politic videos,
is that this doesn't really work.
Now,
it is true that 7 million jobs have been
lost in American industry in the last
decades,
but it isn't because factories have
disappeared.
Not at all.
In fact,
industrial production in the U S is
almost higher than it's ever been.
B,
there's so many jobs have been lost is
not because of the closing of factories,
but because of the new industrial
reality.
Factories need less workers due to
automated systems like robots.
All right?
All right,
so now you might be wondering why you're
telling us all of this.
Isn't this a video without Amazon and
here we are hearing about Donald Trump?
Well,
yes it is.
And here's why.
It's relevance between the impact of
ECOMMERCE,
which is growing more and more popular
plus this scenario of Amazon developing
their automated supermarkets.
It's easy to imagine how many companies
will go bankrupt and the quantity of
jobs that will be lost in this sector
alone.
But you know what?
This isn't necessarily a bad thing.
Oh,
I mean it will be if we don't find a way
to adapt,
but if we do our own marked benefits as
an example today,
if there are more than 100,000
companies working with Amazon who earn
more than $100,000
per year look bad
price,
as always,
the majority of people in businesses are
behind the times.
We are simply not ready and prepared for
the changes that are coming as without
being ready and prepared.
It will be almost impossible to adapt in
time.
But all of that said,
let's take our focus back to Amazon and
to a much more interesting subject,
and that subject is money.
Okay,
gold mine
know.
I knew
what you're thinking.
If Amazon is so successful and it's
worth more than $400 billion,
it's got to be a gold mine.
Right,
and incredible money making machine.
Well not exactly.
At least for the time being.
It is true.
They're results are improving every
year.
Then 2016 when it was no exceptions,
Amazon has submitted record results.
The company has a surplus of two
thousand three hundred and seventy one
million dollars.
That is a lot of money,
isn't it?
But the problem is that if we were to
buy Amazon for that $400 billion in the
company kept returning that amount of
money every year or why they would take
us almost 180 years to recoup our
investment.
So considering this,
it doesn't actually sound like that
great of an investment.
Well,
just to know if a company makes money on
us,
like real money,
I like to try something.
It's a test and that test is to look at
the amount of money,
but it's really coming and going in the
company.
Well,
in the last five years,
Amazon has brought in a surplus of more
than 15 point $5 billion.
The numbers get better,
but it's still relatively low compared
to the purchase price of the company.
So now you might be wondering what
exactly is going on here?
Why is Amazon worth quite so much?
Well,
you see,
Jeff Bezos,
the presidents of Amazon,
has a strategy,
invest all he can to reach new markets
and improve the company's service.
Consider this.
In 2016 Amazon launched prime video to
compete with Netflix and HBO.
Well,
this year Amazon is going to spend $4
billion on films and TV series.
And other example is the so called
project everest.
In the next years,
Amazon is going to invest billions of
dollars in order to come to the market
leader in.
Yeah.
In fact,
it is said that the company is trying to
open hundreds of shops in this country.
So these are the reasons why the company
is worth so much.
Investors expect their business to take
off in the next few years.
Following this,
Morgan Stanley and Credit Suisse to
powerful investment banks expect Amazon
to be the main character of the largest
expansion in the history of business.
How much are we really talking about
here?
Well,
estimates are that in a few years,
the income of Amazon will exceed $500
billion more than four times that of
2016 as well.
Banks understand that,
and that means money is going to
continue flowing through Amazon's vein,
new empire.
It's
like does that mean that Amazon is going
to conquer the world?
So to say?
Now we have to admit that Amazon's
success has been pretty overwhelming and
their company couldn't really be doing
much better.
However,
it's also important to remember that
competition is everywhere.
IBM,
Microsoft,
apple,
Walmart,
Alibaba.
These vast companies are not going to
merely be spectators here and let's
consider the final company.
We mentioned that Ali Baba for Queen of
Chinese e commerce in China.
Amazon has experienced a massive
disappointment despite investing great
deal of money.
Amazon's market share is less than 1%
and wait for more because the Chinese
companies are going to be the talk of
the town for all these reasons.
Div some something that Amazon will
become the Super Company if the 21st
century and builds up to an embalmer
that's on the country or this thing that
it's a fantastic company but it's worth
and expectations are a bit of a bubble
based exaggeration for now though we can
say for sure that there is one clear
winner.
Jeff Bezos is now the world's second
richest person.
Bezos has a net worth of 75 point $6
billion.
But one thing is for sure there is still
a huge battle to be fought in this
relatively new land known as the
Internet.
So that's our opinion here at visual
politic.
And now we would love to know what you
think.
Do you think Amazon will achieve its
goal of taking over?
Well,
pretty much everything.
Well it start making massive amounts of
money or will the competition stop it?
Let us know in the comments below and as
always,
do leave a like if you like this video
and do not forget to subscribe for brand
new videos every Monday and every
Thursday.
Thanks for watching and as always,
I'll see you next time.
If you want to learn more about politics
and hear even more of my lovely voice,
you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsideredmedia.com
slash podcast see you there.